Ці чоловіки насправді фермери.
Тепер вони служать у танковому підрозділі
- одному з найбільш грізних на полі бою.
Воюють на радянському танку Т-80.
40-тонна машина, яка пересувається зі швидкістю до 80 кілометрів на годину,
лякає ворога, каже навідник Василь.
Я вам так скажу: як тільки вони бачать з безпілотників, як йдуть танки,
то вся артилерія спрямована тільки на нас,
вони забувають про піхоту, про все. Значить - бояться.
Але старі радянські танки потребують постійного техобслуговування.
Ось цей, наприклад, на років десять старший за механіка Ігоря. І це видно.
Якщо великі труднощі і перешкоди, ось це біноколь. Він часто лопається.
Потребує заміну. Також періодично проводиться натяжка гусениці.
Ці танки можуть бути старими та зношеними, але їх легко ремонтувати.
Щоправда, за умови, що чоловіки зможуть дістати запчастини.
Часто їх знаходять прямо на полі бою.
Так, багато російських запчастин підходять до нашої техніки.
Ми часто розбираємо трофейні машини на запчастини.
Ходова частина підходить, і частково для мотору запчастини підходять.
На початку повномасштабної війни українці зіткнулися з переважаючими танковими силами ворога.
Але росіяни часто припускалися тактичних помилок, залишаючи танки без прикриття.
Тож, українцям вдалося вивести з ладу або захопити близько 2000 танків.
Але щоб повернути окуповані території, українському війську самому потрібна істотна модернізація.
Тому військові чекають прибуття сучасних танки від країн-партнерів.
Нові більш маневрені, мають інше обладнання - тепловізори, далекоміри...
Їхній екіпаж більш захищений, капсула боєкомплекту розміщена позаду.
Коли вони стріляють, капсула з боєприпасом вилітає в Abrams, а в нас - ні.
У наших старих танках ми сидимо як на пороховій бочці.
Українські танкісти буквально сидять на боєкомплекті танка.
Тому в разі прямого попадання ворожого снаряду ризикують життям.
Нові західні танки розглядають як запоруку успішного українського контрнаступу.
Союзники пообіцяли Україні сотні танків – як сучасних, так і модернізованих радянських.
Станом на тепер в Україну вже прибули перші танки Леопард-2 А6
і Челенджер-2. Зокрема Німеччина передала 18 Леопардів-2,
Норвегія - 8, Португалія - 3, а Польща - 14.
Франція поставила першу партію легких колісних танків АМХ-10 RC - 14 із 40 обіцяних.
А Польща, Чехія і Марокко передали партії модернізованих радянських Т-72.
Так само Леопарди-2 в різній модифікації Україна ще має отримати
від Іспанії, Швеції, Фінляндії та Канади.
А влада Німеччини схвалила передання Україні 178 танків Леопард-1 А5.
У США пообіцяли передати 31 американський танк "Абрамс".
Такі західні танки набагато сучасніші та ефективніші за старі радянські на полі бою.
По-перше, це краща безпека екіпажу танка,
адже всі снаряди перебувають в окремих боксах
і в разі займання вибухова хвиля спрямована в іншому напрямку.
По-друге, мають кращу броню, потужніші двигуни, більшу вогневу міць і дальність гарматного пострілу.
Ми справді маємо згадати часи холодної війни.
НАТО та Захід більшою мірою орієнтувалися на якість.
А російська чи тоді ще радянська сторона - на кількість.
Від українських танкістів ми чули, що ті танки, які вони отримують,
звичайно, набагато сучасніші, ніж танки часів холодної війни.
І це суттєвий крок уперед у порівнянні з танками російського противника.
Наприклад, їхній броньовий захист - вони набагато жвавіші на полі бою.
Не менш важлива і наявність так званих систем управління вогнем
- такі танки можуть вести бій також вночі.
І ще один чи не найважливіший фактор,
це те, що вони зможуть розпочинати бій з російськими танками,
тобто стріляти по російських танках і знищувати їх ще до того,
як російські танки опиняться в безпосередній близькості.
І вони зможуть робити це із дуже високою швидкістю.
За словами західних аналітиків, через санкції Росія
не здатна виготовляти нині сучасну військову техніку,
а сучасних танків на озброєнні у них мало.
Тому РФ здебільшого використовує старі радянські танки,
у той час як українські військові вже проходять
чи пройшли навчання на сучасних західних танках.
Якщо ви зазирнете всередину російського танка,
то зсередини вони досить примітивні,
за винятком найсучасніших, яких у росіян дуже мало.
Коли ви залазите всередину західного танка,
ви оточені електронікою, бронею та сталлю.
Іншими словами, щоб керувати таким танком, як Leopard 2, Challenger або особливо Abrams,
потрібно значно більше підготовки.
Тому те, на чому Захід зосередився, я думаю, останні кілька місяців
і зосереджуватиметься до кінця року,
- це підготовка членів екіпажу.
Але не менш важливим, я наголошую - не менш важливим є і забезпечення логістики,
постачання та ремонту бойових машин.
Вони отримують також не такі, скажімо так, гламурні,
але, безумовно, робочі бойові машини піхоти та бронетранспортери.
Вони також потрібні, бо не можна воювати лише танками.
Вам потрібна піхота. Це помилка, яку росіяни зробили на початку війни.
Утім, щоб розпочати ефективний контрнаступ,
українським військовим потрібно повністю укомплектувати сучасними танками нові батальйони,
тобто дочекатися всіх обіцяних поставок,
а не частинами, впевнені західні військові аналітики.
А доповнити їх мають бойові машини піхоти і велика кількість снарядів.
Як ми бачимо і як ми чуємо, це не та цифра,
яку хотіли отримати і хотіли мати українці.
Тому нам потрібно почекати, гадаю, кілька тижнів,
щоб побачити остаточну кількість, яка прибуде в Україну.
Але що насправді важливо - це те, що ці танки мають кращу якість
і українці добре навчені на цьому новому обладнанні,
я б сказав. Тож це матиме значення на полі бою.
Потрібно набагато більше.
Європейські постачальники "Леопардів", і особливо Німеччина,
обіцяли поки що близько двох батальйонів танків.
Це трохи більше ста танків.
Британці - дуже маленьку, але дуже ефективну роту.
Це 14 танків. Але українці не отримають цих 100 танків,
незважаючи на всі фанфари.
Можливо, вони не отримають 100 аж до осені.
А вони просили 300 танків.
Набагато ефективніше, якщо використовувати їх масово
і так, як хочуть використовувати українці у їхньому контрнаступі
- як масовані штурмові сили.
У великій кількості є експонентний ефект.
З різних причин немає сенсу мати їх у малих кількостях.
Тому їм потрібно набагато більше, і вони продовжуватимуть просити набагато більше.
І вони мають рацію.
Кількома десятками сучасних танків можна створити лише локальну перевагу
над російськими військами. Цього вистачить на 1-2 невеликих наступи.
Починаючи з травня, українці мали перевагу на своєму боці.
Вони задають темп війни.
І, як ми бачили, було три великі виведення російських військ з територій, які вони раніше утримували.
На даний момент є три фронти: це Крим, Бахмут та запорізький.
Якщо коротко, то в Криму українці досягли невеликих успіхів за останні кілька тижнів.
У Бахмуті росіяни досягли невеликих успіхів ціною жахливих втрат.
А на півдні, в Запоріжжі, поки великий знак питання,
тому що це найбільш очевидне місце для українського наступу в 2023 році.
Тому обидві сторони зміцнюються там і вичікують, що зробить інша.
Отже, щоб змінити хід війни, українцям потрібна більша кількість техніки.
Якщо це станеться, ЗСУ зможуть почати контрнаступ на сході та півдні країни.